start to see finishing schools come back
we need to see finishing schools come
back
i did the bouquet of flowers real quick
so we're starting wife's school on a
second channel shout out
you don't think so why the way
society is moving it's making if we look
at the trend more and more men are
being feminized in the sense that
they're
encouraged to talk about their emotions
freely and they're encouraged to
cross-dress and where pain can try
different clothes and women more and
more are encouraged to
excel in their careers
can i add to that point real quick right
as a test to that theory i i text one of
my good friends female friends right
to be fair it was it was a it was an
experiment and it was an actual call for
help right because i was like i just
lost my uh one of my greatest grand
grand arnies
um one of my best artists but it's
technically grant are you however you
work the family system right
um she passed away
and and i and i hit her up like hey
listen
i need to just cry for a minute
have female company
and that's about it
not in a sense not in a sexual sense but
in the sense of i can't cry to my mom
because she's also crying about her
aren't he do you know me
but i needed i needed to
have the ex girl excursion and this was
like a girl you were seeing no no this
was just a female friend oh okay well i
wouldn't do it to a girl scene that
would just ruin the whole relationship
don't consider that as toxic masculinity
it's not okay
um
but at the same time in the back of my
head it was a social experiment because
i i i kind of knew she wasn't gonna hit
me up and be like yeah come come around
cry for a little bit
and then we'll and then we'll like you
know smoke up and then all blessings you
know what i mean like it
it kind of hit me and i was like this is
maybe have i grew up wrong in the sense
of i'm i as a man i'm not supposed to
show emotion or women not supposed to
receive the emotion that i'm feeling but
this is the issue people feel that
because you're a man you can't show your
emotions that's why
there's a lot of people that do suffer
with mh right now because they're not
able to express or they're not being
told to express because especially
emotions it shouldn't be looked upon as
a weakness
but the thing is like women aren't meant
to handle men's emotions women i'm not
meant to but you can be i mean you can
talk teach yourself
you're kind of going against nature
though and that's what's confusing to
men like there's study after study after
study that's gonna tell you that women
lose respect it's not fun this isn't
like a fun part of female nature but
they lose respect for men after we've
seen them cry and a lot of girls will
say they haven't looked at the guy the
same
and like you know i could be like
dishonest and come and say oh yeah like
it's perfectly okay to express your
emotions but it's just not like to for
for a man to express his emotions to i'm
not saying like you can't ever show any
but like if you want to cry in front of
your girl is that a good bet
not not in general so would you look at
a man differently if a man cries in
front of you
um
i would say my dad is one of the people
that i respect more than anyone in the
world like i listen to like pretty much
whatever he tells me
most of the time
but
and i would say one of the reasons i
respect him is he's just always been
very in control of his emotions i can
count i've seen my dad cry
maybe once at his mom's when his mom
died and that's it
and i just think like that level of
respect wouldn't happen if he was crying
once a month twice a year like it just
wouldn't be the same right there is
exceptions to when they're allowed to
cry yeah they don't have to be stone
cold all the time yeah yeah but it's
like
i just think as a girl you trust men
more when they're in control of their
emotions because if i feel like i'm more
like you're more emotional than me
it's like
it's a tough like to trust your judgment
no i agree with that and i'm not saying
a man should cry every month same way a
woman shouldn't cry every month if
there's nothing to cry about
but
the way i look at it with your emotions
like if something severe happens some
men do believe i'm not going to share a
tent
and to to me it's like
but why not because you're still human
at the end of the day you're not made
out still yeah well i think the problem
though is it's very confusing to men
because we don't even know where the
line is
yeah women in general like you don't
know exactly like this is the line where
i start to lose respect for you i
couldn't tell you
i couldn't tell you at what point like
this is like i don't think i don't if a
dude like lost his mother am i gonna you
know judge him for crying no
but i i don't know what point you but i
know there's a point
it's about being able to control your
emotions without suppressing them isn't
it right so it's like okay i'm feeling
i'm feeling this way because of x and
these are the things that i can do to
solve it rather than oh i'm feeling this
way so i'm just going to cry do you know
what i mean like having having a
solution-oriented mindset is what
what men want and what women also look
for in a man as well is being able to
lead being able to be decisive being
able to
so you yeah so it's just an animal to
your point hence that's hence why
i didn't go to like a family member
or like someone someone who was also
sharing the same emotion i was because
at the same time
like
people who are gonna watch the slate one
will be like yo that's the backbone
that's the backbone of the family right
there so for me to show emotion
and to cry
i better be all the way and flip in
norway yeah
i don't think it's a fun part of female
nature like i don't think this is a very
flattering part of ourselves but it just
you know it just kind of is and i and
i'm from uh my my family older head of
the family are female
i'm the oldest boy
so do you feel like the family like
looks up to you to lead would you say
sometimes yeah
if not nine times out of ten
if there's a family barbecue i'm the i'm
the chef so you're grilling
what i'm saying it comes to christmas
ash
do this xyz one two and three yeah i'm
getting it done because that's what it's
expected of a man yeah to get [ __ ] done
it's leadership
that's my point you know what i mean so
when it comes to family
yeah i am the head of my household
even even if the even if i am the uncle
of my nephew's
children
you can call me granddad it's all good
because i've been granddads before when
i was 14 because of my personality and
nature and the fact i work losses
um hannah so you mentioned you talk
about submission on your tic tac account
what is the general response you get
women hate
it they'll say something like
this is misogyny
or standing what submission is in the
context of a healthy relationship
they they think submission and they
think oh being a slave or lowering
yourself for a man
or
being at his backing call or having no
opinions
when submission in a relationship isn't
about that at all it really means that
you're just trusting a man's leadership
and that you respect him to the point
where even when you have disagreements
you're not nagging you're not shouting
at him you're not emasculating him
so
when women understand that then the word
in itself submissive it's so
it triggers people
so i know you said as many of you know i
was just banned on tick-tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible